evolve evolve evolve evolve evolve
hello belive nation today we're going to
talk about how you need to evolve and as
always guys if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down
yourself it's much more likely to stick
with you as well enjoy you can only hope
that as a writer you start trying
different things and you try different
chords or different structures of songs
different beats that you've never really
explored that path before you know and I
think having always been a writer first
I'm obsessed with the syncopation of the
way that words sound when they're said a
certain way and once I've kind of done
something once I always want to go to a
different direction and never repeat
myself so as a writer I think that I've
always hoped that my music would
constantly be changing because you never
want to make the same album twice the
same song twice and you know my greatest
hope has been that as I grow my fans
will grow up with me and as I change and
my life changes my music will change as
well so wish me luck there when I was
younger I didn't really know that you
could just get better at things because
I think we're so used to the idea that
you're talented at something and and
it's sort of fixed you know the idea
that oh he's just a good singer you know
and even with singing I've gotten better
at singing as I've gotten older I wasn't
singing in a way that was sustainable
and I wasn't breathing right I wasn't
doing a bunch of things correctly I
realized that there was a ceiling that I
couldn't crack through unless I actually
studied and worked under a coach to get
better and this idea that things are
just fixed
is proven not to be the case you can get
better at things you can grow and even
people that are innately talented still
need to go beyond that basic talent that
they have and cultivate it I've had to
evolve so many times I've had to change
and grow so many times there's been
times when I made such huge mistakes in
my network marketing career damaged
relationships done things that I wish I
could go back and change but I couldn't
so I could either live there or I could
use that information to grow and become
better see I've been involved for 25
years and I promise you every year
that you that we're engaged we're
working together every year you're gonna
see me get a little bit better and a
little bit better and most of the time
I'm not gonna hit my goals but then I'm
gonna get a little bit better and a
little bit better and compounded over
time you'll see noticeable results
anybody who knows me knows that I'm a
different person than it was five years
ago ten years ago 15 years ago certainly
25 years ago 18 jobs you know barely
surviving so give yourself some grace
understand that nothing is ever finished
while you're still alive it moves on it
keeps going and guess what it's gonna
move on and keep going with or without
you so you know you better adjust to the
changes because if you don't adjust to
the changes man and you say you stay
stuck in the ways that that you've been
moving you're gonna keep getting what
you've been getting out of life and
that's not the way life is meant to be
lived life life is meant to be lived
you gotta constantly evolve you know
change is the basis of growth and growth
is the basis of life if you're not
constantly changing and not growing if
you're not growing then what are you
doing you you're dying you're not doing
nothing so that's why when you look at
certain people man you see them in their
40-something years old they washed up
because they still trying to live the
way they were when they were in their
20s and 30s nothing about them has grown
nothing about them is evolved their
mindset has grown
mm evolved and still hanging around the
same people he was hanging around when
they were in their 20s doing nothing so
guess what if you're hanging around the
same people that you were hanging around
in your 20s doing nothing guess what
you're gonna be doing in your 30s
nothing
so guessed you will be doing your 40s
nothing so you gotta understand life
moves on father time don't wait for
nobody man and when it's over it's over
when you're 47 years old and you look
back at you like damn I wasted all that
time doing nothing
you know life moved on and I didn't move
witty now you're just a washed
individual you got nobody to blame for
that with yourself when you came up with
the Waka Flocka record to this there's
like a big difference in your style of
your approach what's the reason for that
probably because we grow and evolution
is beautiful and like I want to be
iconic and great and I borderline am
iconic and I am great so like it's like
there's only thing left to do is is to
just evolve and continue to do so I mean
like I'm responsible for like possibly
bringing rock'n'roll just in general
into hip-hop within our generation and
like making that whole wave a cool thing
in influencing all those artists when we
were doing those festivals back together
in the 2012 and 2011 2010 years when
wild boy was playing and when so many
other mixtape songs that I was doing
were things so like yes when like I
brought what I brought in and everyone
else took it like I do what all
trendsetters do and I like just set a
new trend and along to the next thing
and let them keep doing you know that
dream team Manoj says I love you but I'm
curious why did you change your rapping
style from the come-up days to today I
love both I don't think I changed my rap
style
um I think you guys were just starting
to hear me and you didn't hear all of me
yet that's it I've always been into
being weird a little bit but I think
what people really mean is that they
think that I've changed my persona and
and life is about growth and change and
I don't want to remain the same for my
whole life I want to be able to change
and you know I respect the people who
loved you know oh seven Nicky and I'm
definitely gonna
view some stuff and on pink Friday like
I'm not forgetting anybody but I just
also have to be true to me and the truth
is I started seeing different things I
started going different places I started
eating different things I can't I it
would be fraudulent to to wrap the same
way and look the same way I act the same
way because I am not the same period I'm
not it well everyone has their different
belief systems I think everyone has
their different opinions of you know
those types of things that you talked
about certainly as an athlete I care
very much what I put into my body I
think that I'm 38 years old I'm not 22
anymore oh good you're very sweet thanks
but I you know all those things are
important and all the little things add
up to be big things so when I'm trying
to accomplish things professionally that
you know in a lot of ways you're in I'm
in unchartered territory so I've got to
do things differently and I got to
evolve over time I've got the things
that may have worked in the past maybe
don't work as you move forward so the
lessons that I've learned through my own
trial and error I think I'm at that
point in my career I'm very efficient
with what I'm doing so I try to eat
healthy I try to get the right amount of
rest I try to do the right types
exercise so I can be on the field and be
available I team I try to be you know as
productive this time in my career as I
was earlier sure we all have to set
goals for ourselves I mean our plan and
destination is to be busy and to you
know adjust to whatever you whatever
you're introduced to and what I mean by
that is okay as an entertainer I started
off as a singer you know I grew to
become a dancer and a performer after
becoming a performer that I became an
actor after becoming an actor I became
an entrepreneur after become an
entrepreneur I became an entertainer on
a different level of introducing other
artists then you know after that I
became a mentor you know so I think just
to continue to evolve in a way that is
beneficial for growth of myself and
others my likeness to continue to be
remembered throughout history
associated with something great for me
you know there's a there's a mantra that
I've I've lived by and it is that the
journey of the destination is really
what it's all about the pursuit is more
important than the actual destination so
as long as you are moving as long as
you're working that is the destination
Wow yeah the journey but really it is
simply that the journey is the
destination I agree as long as you're
working you're are you good fortunate
enough to be honored at the the essence
awards luncheon for the fierce and
fearless award and I was talking to my
girlfriend AJ Johnson who was my trainer
but she's also like a life coach and and
I was like you know do I tell it I mean
if I'm getting an award for being fierce
and fearless do how about I really be
fierce and Phyllis and and explained to
people my my evolution I love Who I am
today but that wasn't always the case I
didn't love you know my features I
didn't love my weight I didn't love my
hair I didn't love my lips and it's been
an evolution and I didn't and I wasn't
always nice or as gracious as I could
have been or happy for other people and
just sort of explain that journey
through my speech when you're building
up to form the one you're obviously
preparing to race but you're not
prepared for what comes along with being
a fun one driver the pressure of such a
big team sponsors media sit in front of
a city you know sit on stage talking
he'd not prepare for that you're not put
through a school or through other
interviews for it so you arrive in the
deep end without being out to swim and I
mean I made a lot of mistakes I got into
obviously I was quick on track
that was know that was the easy part is
everything outside but um lost the first
year in 2007 by one point which was was
you know depending on how serious you
take your job it was emotionally
traumatizing the first year came back
the next year somehow came through that
that experience and then in that last
race I had to finish fifth I started
third I think
was and that was fourth fifth and then
was probably like six laps seven laps to
go or something I was down in sixth and
the guy that was ahead of me was
Sebastian Vettel and there was if you
know I feel I feel if I had to do if I
couldn't do anything even to save my
mother's life if my mom was over there
on the edge of the cliff I had to pass
him to in order to I couldn't get past
him you know I couldn't get past this
guy and for those laps or was just
wasn't giving up but I could see that
dream fading away and and then the last
lap some guy was on sick tires I was on
wets he was stumbling there's quite a
few of them were stumbling I was
overtaking cars here and there I didn't
I had no idea I was that I thought
they're back markers the guy came across
the line and thought he'd for a second
hat was world champion and then I came
across the line seventeen seconds later
and I crossed a line and I thought I
lost the World Championships and my
heart sunk
i I I mean I was distraught and then I
don't know why it took so long but like
12 13 seconds later they told me I lost
world champion and I mean I I didn't
know what the hell was going on and I
think just at the time after that big
whirlwind of media back at the factory
there was so much tension I think I
wasn't I guess I was just I was only 23
so I just don't feel I was don't forget
you know growing up instead of hanging
out with friends on the weekends and you
know doing normal kids social life stuff
I was racing I was with adults so I
missed that a lot my that maturity
growing up stage and I don't feel I was
mature enough to really be able to
embrace the whole experience and enjoy
it sartet it was not a great it was this
amazing that I won the championship it
just wasn't wasn't able to enjoy it and
rolled into the second year the year
after that for example but the last two
championships have really I guess coming
of an age be now to really absorb it and
enjoy the moment because so much work
has gone in from my family so you know I
don't take it for granted the the
opportunity that I have for one there
are so many people that would cut the
leg off to be am I in my seat and do
what I do so I make sure that I just I
maximize every time I get in the car
I'm representing my family every time I
get in that car and so there's nothing
the this there's no time for second
place
of course those experiences when you
have those lows like the work losing the
World Championship only make you
stronger when you do or realize that you
know this Heights and lows see once
you've had the load you appreciate the
house even more so and so presumably
frustrating for you this this season I
mean it's early days yet but it's a
killer season is it's terrible obviously
had a couple of amazing years the last
two I would say this is you know luckily
through the experience of the ten years
of racing you kind of you know you have
the ups and downs and I definitely think
these past five races have been
massively testing for myself my
mechanics from engineers I think each
time I see it as a challenge to rise I
see it as a challenge to you know I'm
gonna be facing the media right now but
I feel terrible I'm angry that I lost
the race or something like that but it's
a moment for me to the kids that are
watching to to me to say the right
things it's a moment for me to lift my
guys up who are probably feeling just as
much as me or you know back of the
factory who worked non-stop to build my
car there's so much going on and I feel
like sometimes I feel often when I do
myself want to do it right I feel
somewhat I come out with so much
stronger and so I do feel this is just a
you know trials and tribulations this is
a period of time of growth for me that
whilst there's always growth
no matter you know I met Nelson Mandela
once in when he was 94 it's not his
birthday and he said to me that he was
still learning at that time so I have a
long way to go
hopefully thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what was your favorite clip what
resonated the most with you what are you
gonna take from this video and
immediately apply to your life or your
business somehow please leave it down in
the comments I'm super curious to find
out thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon